​​Supergirl​ is getting a new look for
season 5 - and it's as much a matter of practicality
than it is of fashion.
The new look was unveiled to fans as San Diego
Comic-Con, and the series' star Melissa Benoist
had a hilarious explanation for fans: she's
tired of freezing her legs off.
Supergirl, AKA Kara Danvers, has undergone
a few slight tweaks to her wardrobe during
the show's run, most notably during season
4's climactic battle with Jon Cryer's Lex
Luthor and the Red Daughter.
That costume switch may have been born of
necessity, but Kara's new look seems to be
more of a direct fashion statement, an evolution
of her classic costume that aligns a little
more closely with the aesthetic of her famous
cousin, Superman.
The biggest difference?
"Pants!
Pants!
Pants!"
According to Benoist, she and the series'
producers simply figured that it was time
for a little update.
But, as Benoist told Entertainment Tonight,
there was another reason for the switch, as
well.
That reason has to do with the fact that Supergirl
shoots primarily in Vancouver, Canada, and
often in the dead of winter.
"Then we moved to Vancouver and it was cold
and it rained, and it feels right, it feels
like the right evolution and the right time
to do it."
Although Benoist has acquitted herself spectacularly
in the role of Supergirl, it's now apparent
that her performance has actually been even
better than she's been given credit for.
If you've ever tried to play it off as if
you're not extremely uncomfortable while freezing
your tail off, you know that it's darn near
impossible.
For that matter, kudos to the cast of the
rest of the Arrowverse series, which also
shoot in Vancouver during those months when
the weather will pretty much kill you if you're
exposed to it for too long.
They, however, have at least gotten to wear
pants for the duration of their shows' runs.
In addition to Kara's new look, Supergirl
season 5 will also feature a decidedly distinct
aesthetic from season 4, which saw the Girl
of Steel thwarting Luthor's plans to sow discord
between the human and alien populations of
Earth.
The season carried some obvious political
overtones, and while the themes explored in
season 5 will be much different, they will
just as topical.
Comic-Con fans were treated to a special preview
of the new batch of episodes which will deal
with society's deepening reliance on technology,
with executive producer Robert Rovner going
so far as to call it the show's "Black Mirror
season."
Kara will also have to deal with the wrath
of her friend - and Lex Luthor's sister - Lena,
who was pretty unhappy to discover that Kara
had been hiding her secret identity from her
for their entire relationship.
The trailer also confirmed that, Lex Luthor,
who had been shot and left for dead by Lena,
was indeed rescued from his fate by the Monitor.
He'll be back to menace our hero in the new
season.
Season 5 has also added a few interesting
supporting characters, including Veronica
Mars' Julie Gonzalo as Andrea Rojas, a businesswoman
with super-heroic aspirations.
Joining her will be Game of Thrones' Staz
Nair as William Dey, a hard-boiled reporter
hiding his connections to the criminal underworld.
Finally, Being Human's Meghan Rath will portray
a female Brainiac 5, joining her real-life
brother, Jesse Rath, who portrayed a male
Brainiac 5 in previous seasons.
We'll see how all of the intrigue and interdimensional
weirdness plays out, as well as how Supergirl
season 5 might connect to the big Crisis on
Infinite Earths crossover slated for this
winter, when the new episodes begin airing
on The CW on October 6.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superheroes are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.